In case you missed it, I'm just back from
a whopping 10 day social media and news hiatus.
Yes, believe it or not it's true, I didn't
look at my Twitter feed or follow current
events for 10 whole days.
Sadly, going offline for more than a couple
hours seems like a super human feat these
days, doesn't it?
Just having one single day without looking
at your phone, without reading the news and
without reacting to someone else's opinion,
most likely someone else you've never even
met, is becoming increasingly rare.
This rarity, the ability to live life without
being constantly connected, is going to become
more and more important as our physical world
continues to collide with the digital world.
We're so connected these days that we can't
stop the onslaught of information for any
amount of time that would allow us to figure
out what's important and what is irrelevant.
Or perhaps more importantly, what's fact and
what's fiction.
It's very obvious to me that occasionally
pausing this endless stream of noise is going
to be one of the biggest challenges that faces
humanity in the next decade.
This challenge will be vital not only for
millennials, but for old time gen Xers like
me as well as the baby boomers who came before
us.
As for the kids growing up with an iPad in
the crib, well good luck with all of that.
By doing pretty much nothing on my vacation
besides laying at the beach, going fishing
and taking bike rides, I was able to reset
a little of this mental clutter.
This reset was kind of tough for the first
couple days, even though I tested my off the
grid skills less than a year ago.
Last time, I literally locked my phone in
a safe for a week to disconnect, but this
time I just put my phone on a shelf in the
closet in a shoe box under a couple other
boxes.
I guess that's some sort of progress right
there.
The first couple days I had the knee jerk
reaction to go to my pocket and look at my
phone for no reason at all on more than one
occasion.
Eventually that wore off and I found a strange
sense of freedom in not being online.
by the final days of my vacation part of me
didn't want to come back online at all.
Apparently while I was off the grid, the world
didn't stop without me.
From the Milo scandal, to Trump banning CNN
from the White House press briefings, to the
Oscars best picture screw up, the world kept
on spinning along.
If you missed it, I did a live stream this
past Monday with my thoughts on some of the
craziness I missed, we'll post the link to
that right down below.
Putting aside these specific news stories
and current events, I noticed something else
as I disconnected from the Matrix.
I actually felt calmer, more present, and
generally happier by being offline.
Now maybe this had something to do with the
beach and the margaritas, but it wasn't just
that.
I don't think our brains are wired to be taking
in endless amounts of information all the
time.
200 years ago to get a message from London
to New York you had to write a letter, get
it on a boat, wait a couple weeks for it to
get there, and then wait another couple weeks
for the response to get back across the pond
to you.
100 years ago our fastest communication was
a relatively new invention known as the telephone
which now seems totally archaic. 50 years
ago we only had a handful of television channels
and 20 years ago cell phones were so big they
made Zach Morris' phone on Saved by the Bell
look small.
Soon enough you'll be able to stream live
video aboard a supersonic plane that will
take you from New York to London in about
20 minutes.
The point is, the world is now speeding up
at an incredible pace, and our own evolution,
the ability for our minds to evolve along
with the technology isn't changing at the
same pace.
I believe this goes a long way to explaining
why people are constantly outraged and always
ready to fight with random strangers online.
Our Connectivity is evolving faster than our
conscience.
There's no way for us to stop this scientific
progress, but we can certainly try to deal
with its side effects more effectively.
And by the way, you've all heard me say how
incredible this online connection can be.
This is the irony of our current situation,
we all have an awesome power at our fingertips,
but it's up to us what to do with it.
As Uncle Ben said to Peter Parker, "with great
power comes great responsibility."
Talking, or more appropriately, fighting about
politics endlessly isn't good for our brains
or for our society.
One of the reasons I'm for small government
is because a good government is one that you
don't have to think about too often.
And if you don't have to think about it too
often, you don't have to tweet about it every
five seconds or write endless Facebook diatribes
about it either.
If the government doesn't have too much control
over your life, you don't have to fixate over
every move it makes or every policy it institutes.
This is always an incredible irony of the
progressive ideology.
They constantly complain about how the government
operates, but their solution is always to
make the government bigger.
If only their guys were in charge then we'd
have some sort of magical utopia.
This isn't only childish thinking, it's also
just against human nature.
The only way to rear in power is to rear it
in regardless of who's in charge.
The feeling that we all have to comment on
every news story, to fight over every political
point and to debate every little issue is
exactly why a smaller government would be
better these days.
Don't like Trump?
The answer isn't to try to upend democracy,
the answer is to reign in the power of government.
If we could only live and let live as our
founders intended, we would spend less time
worrying, fighting and distracting ourselves
from our own lives.
So to wrap this up I'm deleting this channel,
closing my Twitter account and shutting down
my Facebook.
We've had a good run with The Rubin Report,
but nothing lasts forever.
Just kidding, but I am going to make a renewed
commitment not add meaningless noise to your
already hectic life.
Now share this video with everyone you know
or the world as you know it will come to a
horrible end.